e aí
e eu queria começar convidando vocês
para olhar essa foto me deu o quê que
vocês tão vendo
ela é uma menina brincando de boneca
hum será que é uma menina brincando de
madrasta em thiaguinho
oi ou é uma menina brincando de mamãe
esse linha que não é seu
e não
e isso não é verdade essa menina da foto
não sou eu
e no brasil 1 em cada 3 casamentos
terminam em divórcio
oi e eu faço parte dessa estatística
porque os meus pais se separaram também
oi e aí
e eu vi a minha mãe se tornar madrasta
e eu ganhei uma madrasta até que tava
tudo bem
e até que um dia sim para cinco anos eu
virei madrasta má
e aí
como vocês devem ter visto alguns meses
uma polêmica na internet pedindo para o
google mudar definição brasileirissima
da palavra a professora tava escrito
professora é uma prostituta com quem
adolescentes iniciam a vida sexual
tá todo mundo aqui sabe que professora
não é isso e por quê que isso importa
se importa porque o jeito que a gente
definir as coisas pode reforçar ou não
um estereótipo
e eu fiquei muito curiosa e fui procurar
lá então
qual o significado da palavra padrasto
o cadastro alguém que apesar de não ser
o pai biológico recebe responsabilidades
paternas
e quando ele casa com uma mulher um
homem que já tem filhos
o ok né
oi e aí eu fui procurar na definição de
madrasta
a madrasta no sentido figurado é uma
mulher má
e capazes sentimentos afetuosos
amigáveis também pode piorar porque
madrasta é aquilo que de que provém
vexames e de sabores em vez de amor e
carinho
olá eu sou uma mulher mar tem capaz de
sentimentos afetuosos amigáveis
a nossa
e no dia vinte e oito de novembro de
2014 até umas 8 horas da manhã eu era
uma pessoa legal
e foi naquele dia que eu conheci o meu
marido e eu virei essa mulher marra
tá mas o que que de fato é madrasta
a madrasta significa mulher do pai
o e vem do latim mater que vem de mãe e
aí vocês podem estar pensando não mas
ela é uma boa graça
e a gente definir como boadrasta presume
aqui e madrasta é ma ma
e esse encontro de duas jornadas de uma
mulher e de crianças
e vende lugares muito diferentes eu tava
muito feliz eu conheci um cara legal
casei as crianças estavam vindo
diretamente de uma separação de um
divórcio
e esse é o encontro das duas jornadas
isso a gente pensa que é desafiador para
gente como adulto imagina para criança a
criança agora tem duas casas
e a criança talvez veja os pais brigando
a criança talvez veja modelos
educacionais muito diferentes e você tá
lá entrando nessa família
e quando você decidir engravidar você
pode participar de um grupo de gestantes
e você pode participar de um grupo de
gestantes que querem ter o parto na água
você pode participar de um grupo de yoga
talvez você possa participar de um grupo
de yoga que quer fazer o parto na água
enquanto fazia logo ou qualquer coisa
assim
e quando você vir a madrasta quem te
acolhe
os pais recém-nascidos têm as pracinhas
e as escolas como pequenas comunidades
que acolhem esse momento novo mas quem
acolhe as madrastas
o seu vicente
o vicente a mesma enteado mais novo
quando ele tinha mais ou menos 17 anos
e ele chegou em casa e perguntou mari
porque você nunca vai na reunião da
minha escola
hoje eu olhei para ele e falei porque
fica melhor de paz e eu não sou faz eu
sou madrasta e ele respondeu alguma
coisa tipo isso não é justo aí eu não é
legal
e eu sabia que aquela não era uma boa
resposta para ele nesse dia a gente se
olhou e se deu conta de que a gente tava
querendo ver no mundo não tava
acontecendo e a gente decidiu na escola
a gente foi na escola do vicente falou
com a diretora contou para ela que tinha
acontecido
e ela olhou para gente falou como eu
nunca pensei nisso naquele dia toda a
comunicação das três saídas da escola
virou família
e reuniões de família
as celebrações de família convites para
famílias
e quando você conhece um cara que já tem
filhos
bom e você vai contar para alguém
e a pessoa vai te responder em pacote
completo
é a minha família não é um pacote
e no meio disso tudo
e eu engravidei
ah e outra chuva de estrela ótimos
caindo em cima de mim
e agora
e você vai entender que agora o filho é
seu
e agora você vai amar de verdade quando
foi que a gente esqueceu de todas as
crianças desse mundo merecem ser amadas
por todas as pessoas desse mundo
e esse é o augusto meu penteado mais
velho eu tava com barrigão já e muito
ansiosa porque eu não fui capaz de
escolher um nome para minha própria
filha
oi e aí um dia a gente chegou em casa na
mesa do jantar começou a conversar e
falar sobre nomes e o augusto falou ela
vai chamar flora
i am
oi e esse nome reverberou na gente a
gente não teve nenhuma dúvida que ela ia
se chamar flora
e essa mágica continuo porque a flora
tinha data prevista para nascer em
outubro e ela nasceu dia 22 de setembro
às 9:30 da noite e a primavera tinha
começado a 5 e 6 daquele dia
a e nesse dia os meus enteados deixaram
de ser apenas os meus enteados eles
viram os irmãos da minha filha
e aí
a mudar os estereótipos histórias e as
narrativas depende da gente não somos as
pessoas que compõem as famílias de hoje
os casais homoafetivos
os casais transgênero relacionamentos
poliamorosos
os pais divorciados pais e mães solo
as crianças adotadas casais sem filhos
eu acho que a gente está sendo bem
criativo para combater o modelo do
patriarcado
e esse vocês estão aí pensando o que
vocês tem a ver com isso
há mais ou menos assim
e eu faço um convite para vocês seja um
aliado
e quem tem que decidir o que é amor
cuidado e afeto dentro da nossa família
é a gente
e você pode não aceitar estereótipo você
pode não aceitar o preconceito
oi e para terminar eu tenho um pedido
o google vou da nossa definição aí vai
obrigada
[Aplausos]